how to resolve the northern island
border issue by accepting EU rules on
Goods and food she thinks she solved it
is she right join me now to discuss the
shadowed northern island secretary Tony
Lord mr. white
very good morning to you we volunteer at
indeed we've all had a couple of days
noted to digest that which is a match
from checkers what did you make of it
well we've not really had a couple of
days to digest it because until we have
the white paper published it's really
going to be very difficult to know
everything that's in there but there are
a couple of things that are very obvious
this is a political fudge and without
pushing us an analogy too far that's no
better than any other kind of fudge it
was designed and not very successfully I
think to keep the Conservative Party
together not to pursue that the nation's
interest and there are two issues
obviously one is the the question of
that of the hard border it's simply not
obvious that that's been solved and the
second thing of course is the the very
real issue around around security when
we've had warnings from Cressida dick
the head of the Metropolitan Police
Force warnings from George Hamilton the
the chief constable of the police
service in Northern Ireland
about the the need on security grounds
to to get the right deal with with our
you partners as we leave and so within
that a political
fix fine to keep the show on the road
not good enough for this country of ours
so in terms of the agreement that was
met on for example freedom of movement
what appears to be a common market for
goods you know that changes with Labor's
position then no it doesn't you know
that it would be great if Therese made
recognized the almost the inexorable
logic of why in the end Britain will
have to end up in the the position that
Labour's put forward what we still got
is this really rather bizarre promise of
some technological fix that nobody as
yet believes can be made to work where
goods coming into this country will will
be differentiated from those traveling
through Britain into the rest of the
European Union nobody knows
that can be done and that's why we've
already had words from different parts
of Industry and Commerce warming that
we're not there yet now obviously if
Therese may is genuine the honor journey
in the right direction that's great but
can she drag the rest of the
Conservative Party whether because that
really frankly is the difficult issue
and we want this country of ours to be
in a proper customs union with the
European Union into the future that's in
the interests of no hard border in
Ireland it's actually frankly though in
the interests of trade in goods for the
rest of the United Kingdom
constituencies like my own in the north
of England does need that no hard border
it across the English Channel
as well as no hard border across the
island of Ireland we're not there yet
but just in terms of your breather mean
what what exactly in your mind is the
problem with it that this solution
that's been found this kind of common
trade area it appears to tick all the
boxes I don't think it does though does
it you know what we've got still is is a
situation that's going to rely on the
kind of technology that doesn't yet
obviously exist what it seems that it's
still being said is that somehow we can
differentiate between goods traveling to
and fro it from through Britain into the
European Union of course that's the in
incidentally the Irish Republic from the
Norton not from the north of Ireland and
it's not really yet obvious that that's
compatible with what with what to
resumes put forward now within that's as
well there is another major issue on
this is the European Union going to be
prepared to negotiate on this basis
because that's a fundamental issue as
well what we do know is that if we were
saying that we'd be part of a customs
union equivalents of the customs union
that now exists we could guarantee that
God could travel across the border in
Northern Ireland but frankly could
travel across any other border between
the rest of the UK and the Netherlands
there France etc that's actually what
the whole of the UK needs but it's most
certainly what no hard bordering island
needs otherwise we've got to heed the
warning sir
border is potentially devastating for
the progress that's been made in across
the island abound and for the rest of us
in the UK over the last 20 years we
can't put that at risk I mean do you
agree with you with your colleague Osama
that there should there could
potentially be a second referendum I
don't think he Osama has said that's a
listen to him very carefully this
morning I think most was probably the
view and then when I say most of those
most people in this country that
obviously we need an the meaningful vote
in parliament should be able to say when
treason may comes back that the deal is
is an acceptable one she's gonna have
trouble with her own I don't quite
understand you I mean he does what so
kia said it is Parliament as you were
saying that should decide what happens
next it should have the power to decide
the options and this might involve a
general election or a people's vote we
did say it could involve I think most of
us this is the point it's an option with
the Liberal Party is keeping open at the
moment I think the best option for this
country at that point would be a general
election because this isn't something
it's such a complicated issue what we
need is a political party prepared to
take power who has a very clear view of
the nation's interests that's obviously
one that the Conservative Party with all
this division can no longer do and quite
frankly that's where general election
would be the right answer
it's a problem with all of this mr.
Lloyd is that I thought that generally
Corbin had ruled it out a general
election I don't believe the people's
vote
well the Labour is never committed
itself to the people's vote and I think
those are the words that Kirsten mused
this morning what he said was that
labour hasn't pursued that line or words
that effects and that's where we are and
I must say I generally do believe the
best vote would be real people's vote
and that's the general election because
that is how the public and in toto can
make a decision on not simply the merits
of the the deal that comes back but
actually importantly the way we take
forward a strategy and the policy that's
in the interests of the people of the
United Kingdom we need a united
government we've not got one with the
present
Conservative Party I mean it strikes me
and mr. Lloyd that there's enough fudge
around this morning to fill a sweetshop
well it's certainly the food to be
thrown around this weekend I'm not quite
sure explain to me where the fudge is in
what I've sudden they Bell respond
they're more clearly Jeremy Corbyn
reeled out of people's bought pierced
armor says yet still on the table which
is it what's Jeremy Corbyn said and just
the other day is the best outcome that
this would be a general election that's
what I'm saying again this morning what
chaos Thomas you've repeated said is
that it has not been part of Labor's
thinking that there would be a second
vote what he went on to say is if
Parliament decides that the deal is so
unacceptable clearly it has got to be a
further mechanic and that further
mechanic my own preference
very clearly jeremy corbyn's preference
think in the interest the people of the
United Kingdom would be a general
election and pierced armor also did talk
about a general actually no footage
there I think that's very clear
whatsoever you mr. Lloyd I just want to
talk about that the new anti-semitism
could there's been adopted by the Labour
Party it excludes a number of behaviors
which you the international Holocaust
Remembrance Alliance say are
anti-semitic can you explain why it is
nor your people would no longer be
punished within the Labour Party for
saying that which Ken Livingstone did
you know Hitler was a Zionist well in
fact what Labour's is most certainly
committed to is that will match up to
the standards of the in such is the
international Holocaust Remembrance
Association because that is something
that's been adapted and adopted
throughout that the the length and
breadth of this country of ours
what Labour's tried to do though on top
of that is to make it something that is
applicable that Labour conditional is in
the event of people breaching that
standard now with it within that and I'm
clear I'm clearly advised that that
would include the situation if Ken
Livingstone for example there are people
there are people who have been suspended
from your party for saying and I'm
paraphrasing here of course you know
Israelis are effing Nazis you know since
this real change that would not be
considered anti-semitic by the Labor
Party well I think it would
and the important points about this is
that labor is still in consultation with
different Jewish organizations obviously
we've got to listen to what's not the
positive we've got to listen to what
people are saying back to us and making
sure that the standard we come up with
is one that conforms to the standards
the IHRA
but importantly also allows us to
operationalize that in practical terms
to take action where this breach from
that that what isn't a high standard
what is an acceptable standard to make
sure that my own party which has always
had a very strong connection with the
British Jews amongst other communities
and is able to face the future to say we
are a party committed to anti-semitism
that's why we've got to get to and
that's where we will get to we've got a
pretty famous visitor arriving in the
United Kingdom next week the President
of the United States will you be
participating in any of the protests
flying the odd blimp or - I don't think
I'd be flying the odd blimp and what is
clear is that Donald Trump is very
unusual by standards of American
presidents that we've dealt with in my
lifetime where we've had a very close
relationship on the ways we think but
this is a Donald Trump who's abrogated
standards around climate changes has
kicked the the really important seer and
nuclear deal into touch and it's a
president who is now talking about the
possibility of downgrading NATO of doing
deals with a President Putin who not
that long censors invaded parts of the
Ukraine and he just caused great issues
great problems I think it's really
important that that our government to
resume is is making it very clear that
there are limits to our own capacity to
work with the president who is so out of
kilter with what Britain but actually
the rest of those countries who
historically have been part of the the
Western alliance the Western Way of
thinking a committed - and I hope Donald
Trump will now seriously listen and not
simply not simply respond to what he
sees is the domestic pressures on him in
the United States the world is bigger
than than simply
small parts of the US and we've got to
make sure that we've got that that that
conversation relationship with the
American president mr. Lloyd it looks a
lovely day in Manchester we'll let you
go and enjoy many thanks for being with
us at and thanks to you